we're going to talk this morning about
proving things now proving things in
mathematics is a really big deal that's
why you've been doing it for so very
long
it's one of the best things I love about
mathematics it actually can prove things
I know beyond a shadow of a doubt for
the rest of time in history no matter
where you are in the universe these
things are true that's different to
every other field of knowledge that we
have for example in science when I was
your age I was taught the atoms look
like this and we had evidence for that
model like you know there's protons and
neutrons in there and and there's like
these little electrons whizzing around
and doing their thing and then sometime
after I left high school like we knew
this but it just hadn't caught up to a
high school education yet
sometime after high school they'll by
the way you know how we prove this
before actually that's totally not what
atoms look like they look like something
completely different
there's none of this like nice
predictable sort of spinning around
there's more about it's more like
they're kind of the electrons might be
here or they might be there or they
might actually be here and here but no
one really knows and it's just kind of
just Cloud of Unknowing more in the
cluster so it's like oh no my whole
world is collapsing around me and the
reason why that is it's not because
science is wrong but the model of
knowing things in science is we look at
the evidence and then we literally make
something up that fits that evidence and
it look if it works pretty close then we
say that thing that we made up is what
we call a model right and it can predict
what happens in the world this model can
predict a lot of things which is why we
used it for so long but once we discover
new evidence that maybe gives us a finer
or a better understanding we say yeah
you know let's let's let's ditch that
even though we scientifically proved it
before science moves on that's exactly
what science does in fact that's its
primary goal to come with better and
better models and advance our knowledge
of things okay and it's all completely
different to what a mathematician pru
something it's true forever
that's why we study Pythagoras despite
the fact that
is centuries millennia old because the
stuff he proved a squared plus B squared
equals C squared it's just as true today
as was back then and it will still be
true forever right so that is why
mathematicians make such a big deal out
of proof now most of the kinds of proof
you've ever had to deal with are all
actually really one kind of breed of one
species of proof but there's a whole
animal kingdom out there as it were of
kinds of proof and all we're going to
look at is proof by contradiction so to
understand that today I want to contrast
that to stocking for you already know to
be true X Y and then what if I add up
280 okay now how do we know that to be
sure how can we prove it let's just
really quickly rehearse what the proof
looks like okay I'm go ahead and draw
this probably the simplest way that I
know to prove this is to put a
construction on this okay the
construction I'm going to make is a line
through this angle that's parallel to
the opposite side I actually could do
this construction
whichever which way it will just be
easier if we do it right way up so I'm
going to construct this line over here
which is parallel okay now if those
lines are parallel then I know some
things about the angles that I've just
created through this construction okay
for instance this angle over here what's
it equal to Y and the reason for it
being why is that good you can see the
relationship here between these two
angles because you have these parallel
lines and likewise you can say that this
angle is said their degrees right so for
that reason by definition we say that
angles on a straight line adds 180 but
that x y&z is the same x y&z that are
inside the triangle so so I'm done you
know this is very different by the way I
hope you guys have done the experiment
where and I say experiment very
deliberately where you can take a don't
cut my cable that'll be clever you can
take a triangle any triangle have you
done this before
I hope you've done it it's kind of like
a staple of the mathematics part
you take your triangle right and then
you can be even even ruder than that you
just just rip the the triangle up into
three pieces so long as the pieces each
have an angle in them okay and then if
you put them on let's see how I do this
one and then two and then three you'll
get the same straight angle that I just
drew constructed on the board okay the
difference between this and what we've
just done is that I just proved it
underneath research for this particular
triangle and we could do this you know
ten times and we'd have a lot of
examples and that will constitute like
the mechanism of scientific proof proof
by example proof by repetition okay but
in mathematics we don't care about
repetition you can repeat something
correctly a million times and it all
looks good but that doesn't constitute
like the millions and first time might
disprove it right so that's why we use
logic rather than example now underneath
where you've um written that I basically
want you to get this structure it's very
simple this is the way that we would
describe the logical sequence of what
has just happened right if we have some
statements a and B if we know that one
is true then we use logic to infer that
the other is true okay all the proofs
that you even done so far I like this so
we wanted to prove that the anal summer
train 180 degrees what knowledge did we
rest on to be able to do that there was
a few bit but there was probably one
important work how do you know that this
is why again what knowledge did you use
that often angles ultimately was on on
power lines are equal right so this is
something which you we've established to
be true right and can be demonstrated
very easily and then we use that to get
to here okay now proof by contradiction
is exactly what it sounds like
instead of doing this like everything is
true everything is true what you do is
you assume that the thing you want is
false right now
for example you might say let's assume
the angle something trying 181 degrees
okay if you assume that you're going to
run into problems because things will
contradict themselves you'll run into
like oh wait but these angles are 181
but we know that that can't be because
they're all in a straight line okay
so therefore underneath here what you
want to write is the structure of a
proof by contradiction is as follows
proof by okay rather than doing this
right and going forward as it were what
you do is you take the stain that you
want to prove that's B right and then
say assume that it's false assume B is
false now if if this is really true then
this assumption is going to lead to some
problems okay because it's it's not it's
not actually accurate so because this is
inaccurate that's actually the way I'm
going to say it because this is
inaccurate we should be able to come up
with a contradiction that results from
it
once we find that contradiction we can
say wait this is this is all the logic
worked out so the problem mustn't be the
logic the problem must be where we
started right which should be is false
well they must be true because we ran
into this problem the contradiction that
you end up with is either one of like
fundamental logic some pre-established
fat or something about like some
additional piece of information in the
question like this